So the question then becomes, how might
an error agent learn from its mistakes?
Learning by correcting mistakes, or
learning from failures, really entails
answering three separate questions.
The first question is, how can the agent
isolate the error in its former model?
So the agent had some
model of the world.
It made a mistake based on its model,
how can it identify
the error in its model?
Note that this particular problem
is very closely connected
to the equation of diagnosis
that we discussed earlier.
The second question is how can the agent
explain to itself that default it has
identified the error in fact led
it to the problem to the failure.
Having identified the fault and
explained how the fault
led to the failure.
The third question is how can
the agent repair the fault
in order to prevent the error,
the failure from recurring.
You may have noticed that earlier,
we had related learning by correcting
mistakes with matter cognition.
You can see how that
relationship occurs.
The agent has some
knowledge of the world.
That knowledge leads it to failure.
The agent is using that failure
to repair it's own knowledge.
It is as if the agent is looking into
itself, looking into it's own reasoning,
into it's own knowledge and
correcting itself.
Note once again that the learning
here is incremental.
We are learning from
one example at a time.
However instead of simply
learning from an example
we are also using
explanation-based learning.
We're trying to explain why a particular
fault led to a particular failure.
An explanation connects them with
explanation that's learning,
not just with the notion
of incremental learning.
Let us see how these three questions
occur in the example of the pail.
The first question is how
can the agent identify that
the fact that this particular
pail has a moveable handle,
not a fixed handle, is why this
is not a good example of a cup.
The second question is how can the agent
with an explanation that proves why
having that moveable handle makes
this the poor example of a cup.
Why does that lead to a failure?
The third question is how can
the agent change its model of a cup so
that it never again picks an object with
a movable handle as an example of a cup.
>> So when we talked about
explanation-based learning,
we used another example of this as well.
We imagined a desktop assistant
that I can just say hey,
fetch me that important
file from last Tuesday.
And it can construct it's own
understanding of what file I might
be talking about.
It has a notion of what files have
been important in the past and
certain criteria of those files.
So constructs an understanding
of what important is and
tries to transfer that onto
files from last Tuesday.
Now imagine that I told this agent hey,
fetch me that important
file from last Tuesday.
And it returns me a file that
actually wasn't important.
And I say hey, that file isn't
actually important at all.
The agent would first try to isolate
what error it made in diagnosing
that particular document as important.
You might, for example, notice that
every other document I ever labeled as
important was very recent
whereas this one was really old.
So even though it met all the criteria
for an important document
there might be more criteria
that it didn't consider yet, and
one of those might be that only
new documents are very important.
It would then explain that the problem
came from the assumption that
an old document could be important, and
it would It would then repair its model
to say that in the future old documents
can't be important, even if they meet
the other criteria for importance.
>> This problem identifying the error in
one's knowledge that led to a failure
was called credit assignment.
Blame assignment might be a better term.
A failure has occurred.
What fault of gap in one's knowledge
was responsible for the failure?
That's blame assignment.
In this lesson, we'll be focusing on
gaps or errors in one's knowledge.
In general, the error could be in one's
reasoning or in one's architecture.
Credit assignment applies to all
of those different kind of errors.
Several Herculists, Marvin Minsky for
example, consider credit assignment to
be the central problem in learning.
This is because error agents
live in dynamic worlds.
Therefore, we'll never be able to
create an error agent which is perfect.
Even if you were to create an error
agent which had complete knowledge and
perfect reasoning that
lives in some world,
the world around it
would changed over time.
As it changes,
the agent will start failing.
Once it starts failing, it must have
the ability of correcting itself,
of correcting its known knowledge,
correcting its own reasoning,
correcting its own architecture.
You can see again how this
a record of meta cognition.
The agent is not diagnosing
some electrical circuit or
a car or software program outside.
Instead, it is self diagnosing,
self repairing.